Salut à tous, c'est Pêcheurs de trésors.
Aujourd'hui, on est sous un énorme
pont très prometteur.
On est dans une petite ville
Petite ville, mais bien passante.
Et puis il y avait déjà des
cartouches de calibre douze au bord
C'est un très bon indice.
Ça montre que cela a été fait,
mais il en reste toujours.
Et puis peut être qu'ils
n'ont pas trouvé le fusil.
C'est super lourd.
Après, là, pour soulever sans aller dans l'eau...
Il faut le faire basculer
de l'autre côté
Débloque l'aimant
Et on le fait basculer
Je vais dans l'eau si vous voulez
Tu vas être écrasée dessous
Allez.
Sors le
On a pas commencé encore à pêcher
et Quentin est déjà dans l'eau,
ça s'annonce bien.
Sidney n'a pas l'habitude
Voilà, vas y
Parfait. OK,
c'est du beau matos
c'est beau
Mais je
suis sûr que ça pourrait intéresser des gens
Ça peut intéresser du monde. Ça.
C'est surtout que c'est d'époque
Moi, j'ai. Vu la forme,
tu peux en faire quelque chose.
C'est un truc que tu ne trouves pas de partout ça
Au poids de la ferraille ça ne vaut pas grand chose
Non, non, non, non, je pense.
Ce serait plus pour de la décoration
On va le faire rouler un peu là bas et après on monte l'autre côté
Je vais attacher l'autre côté
On le fait basculer
Voilà
Aller
C'est une sorte de draisienne
ou quelque chose comme ça,
Ouais c'est pas si ancien
Enfin relativement récent
Mais là du coup on soulève ?
Bon oui, c'est déjà bien.
Je ne vais pas pouvoir vous aider beaucoup
ne vous cassez pas la tête
Attention au dos
Ce en sont pas les meilleurs gestes
Mais aujourd'hui j'ai 70 ans, alors...
Et bien bon anniversaire !!
Bon aniv !
Tu soulèves ? Vas y !
Attention qu'il ne roule pas.
Bon bah c'est bien, bien joué,
ça commence bien.
C'est une première pour nous, ça.
Dites nous en commentaires
Si vous avez des idées,
il y a toujours des pros
en commentaires
qui peuvent reconnaître
le moindre objet.
Donc là je vous le film bien.
Si vous avez des idées
on continue.
Ouais ouais.
Ouais ouais au moins tu as trouvé
un bon point d'ancrage pour.
C'est mieux de lancer d'en haut en vrai
Pour avoir plus de distance
Ah il y a des choses,
Qu'est ce qu'on a ?
Une pile électrique, une grosse
Belle trouvaille, hop !
Bonne dépollution de dépollution,
comme dirait Quentin
Ah oui, une petite cuillère de pêche
quand même.
Une pièce, regarde
Ça, c'est un demi Franc
0,50€ de francs.
De quelle année ?
Pas si ancien
Mais c'est sympa.
Nous sommes aujourd'hui
à Agen Quentin
Ouais comme les pruneaux.
Pour une petite partie de pêche à l'aimant
Voilà, on était très constipés,
on a décidé de s'arrêter
et puis finalement,
on a aussi décidé de pêcher un peu
On va voir ce qu'on trouve là
Une moto, non une voiture,
ça va te plaire.
C'est une sorte de camion en jouet
Bon, il a pris cher,
mais ça devait être un joli camion,
je pense.
Ce spot m'a l'air bien.
Il y a des choses, Baptiste
Première remonté avec quelque chose ?
Oh oui, il y a de l'algue
Qu'est ce que c'est que ça ?
Mouais.
OK
Mais ce n'est pas tout, c'est
pas tout.
J'ai ça aussi
C'est pas une matraque, ça.
Si, c'est presque la même que la mienne
C'est une matraque ?
Télescopique. Ouais elle n'est plus trop télescopique maintenant
On dirait qu'elle a tapé quelqu'un
vu comme elle est pliée
ça a servi
La petite matraque c'est pas mal
ça fait plaisir.
Pour le coup, c'est une première.
On compare avec notre matraque là,
ça ressemble, hein ?
Ne demandez pas pourquoi
on a des armes.
C'est juste pour comparer.
Si jamais on trouve
Mais celle là elle a servi
Oui mais c'est normal
Mais la plupart des matraques quand tu les ouvres elles ont toujours un angle
une partie tordue. De base.
Donc pour avoir le sens,
Je ne sais pas ce que ça vaut...
je pense qu'elle est morte.
De toute façon ce n'est pas de la qualité
Allez, qu'est ce que tu ne trouves ?
Des armes
un peu plus lourdes, j'espère.
Qu'est ce que c'est ça ?
Quentin regarde,
il y a des piles non ?
tonka
Puis il y a une munition surtout.
Ah non, non, fausse alerte,
j'ai cru.
Ouais !
C'est quoi ?
Une moto ?
Super.
Il y a la plaque,
donc on va appeler la police
pour voir si elle est volée.
Je pense que oui,
elle était plus facile à remonter
que celle à Narbonne,
mais y a pas mal d'objets.
En fait, il y a pas mal d'objets
qui y viennent, pas forcément.
Allez, je vais essayer de tirer
Sur la pale planche d'en face
d'en face. Non.
Une petite fourchette,
euh cuillère, cuillère.
Voilà, j'ai quelque chose les gars.
C'est dans les algues
c'est un aimant ça
je crois,
mais un aimant d'enceintes.
Si je dis pas de bêtises,
Dommage il est mort
Qu'est-ce que c'est Rasta, elle fait bêtises ?
La copine
Allez.
Montre nous ce que t'as trouvé.
C'est pas très lourd, mais
ça peut être intéressant.
Bon, c'est plein de clous,
c'est rempli de clous. Oh non...
Bon courage mon pote
Quel enfer !
Oh la misère.
C'est quoi le truc blanc ? c'est nul.
C'est un flexible de douche.
Mais éclaté. Amuses toi
bien pour enlever tout ça.
Ouais.
Il y avait quoi?
On a encore 50 centimes de franc
Faudrait le nettoyer.
On regarde ça après, Op
Alors ouais, ouais, ouais.
Qu'est ce que c'est ça ?
C'est ce que je.
Sais pas trop, ce que c'est.
Une idée
Un cadenas
Ou un loquet de porte de volets
Ah non, attends.
Est ce que ce serait
pas un jeton de supermarché ?
Ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur.
Le truc, c'est un truc de caddie.
Peut être.
Et la pièce on ne voit plus l'année...
Là Baptiste tu viens de jeter une pièce dans le seau
Un Franc encore
T'as raison cette pièce là est illisible
Elle est trop abimée
Donc c'est bien un Franc 1968.
1968.
J'ai quelque chose parmi les algues
plein de choses.
Un patin à roulettes,
Un reste de patin à roulettes
de patinettes
Tu penses ?
Alors il y a le dessus aussi.
J'avais les mêmes
Il y a le dessus
Ça, c'est vieux, ça
Non c'est pas le dessus
Oui, c'est ça.
C'est ça.
Mais ça, c'est tellement vieux. Ça.
C'est oui, toujours les mêmes, hein.
Allez, une trouvaille.
Un poids correct,
c'est pas aller dans le bord Oh.
Un cadre, enfin une fourche.
Une fourche.
De vélo,
Tu aurais pus le remonter entier quand même.
Quentin t'abuses
Et encore un morceau du vélo.
Oh regarde,
on reste dans le jouet ancien
Un soldat
Il était peut être sur la moto,
il est aimanté ?
Il ne va pas sur la moto
Vérifie sur l'aimant s'il est magnétique
S'il est en fer
Non non
Je l'ai eu grâce aux vis
périmé depuis 1998,
c'est ton année naissance, non ?
Ouais, c'est pas mal,
donc c'est là depuis un bon moment
avec ça.
Regardez, on a fait ça.
À mon avis, c'est
un truc électrique.
Il y a du câble électrique, quoi
Et moi, je continue.
Ici, il y a pas mal de choses
en s'éloignant du pont
Déjà, il y a une lime
lime à bois
ça, c'est un aimant non ?
Je connais pas la différence avec une lime à fer
Bonne question.
En vrai.
Ça, tu le vois au quadrillage
Ah quadrillage
qui est plus plus prononcé je crois.
Pour le bois.
Regarde ça c'est un aimant
Sympa hein
une plaque en fonte ?
ça vient sûrement d'une cheminée
t'es prête pour t'envoler ?
le reste du vélo
OK, super,
Et avec ça, du cuivre
la bobine de cuivre. Là
Oh
Ah ça, c'est un Tamagotchi.
Non, c'est pas ça.
Si. Yes.
j'ai la référence
Toi aussi t'en avais un ?
A conserver ça
C'est rigolo
pour ceux qui connaissent pas, c'est
une sorte de petit animal
qu'on devait nourrir.
Un poussin.
Un poussin celui-là, ok
Voilà, regardez une pile déjà
belle dépollution.
On va la mettre là bas
une cuillère
On va regarder aussi, on
garde les couverts pour l'électrolyse
Et ça, c'est un filtre à gazole,
donc ça n'a
absolument rien à faire dans l'eau.
Et encore un morceau du vélo
qui est vraiment démonté
en petits morceaux.
Ou encore le morceau de vélo.
Une jolie cuillère.
Ça donne le style.
Ouais, c'est de la merde,
Juste le manche
est original, mais
c'est tout plat.
Et voilà
donc encore un morceau de mon vélo
alors.
Le couteau
avec celui là, il est beau.
Pour une fois, il a été aiguisé
Tu nous sors quoi de beau ?
Ça, c'est la trouvaille
de la journée.
La dernière fois que j'ai dis ça, ça l'a été vraiment
Ah ! On y croit alors
Oh oh encore un outil.
C'est une clé,
une grosse clé à molette.
Ouais, joli.
C'est presque la trouvaille du jour
Aujourd'hui. C'est pas incroyable.
Je préfère quand même la matraque
C'est pas mal aussi. Ouais,
une vraie cuillère.
Cuillère à crack. Elle est brulée
Non elle est rouillée
Alors qu'est ce que j'ai moi,
au Mais oui, c'est bon ça,
c'est un aspirateur, non ?
C'est un couteau électrique
Oui. J'ai les manches qui vont avec en plus
Ouais, mais bon.
Ça me rappelle ma mère.
Quand elle coupait, le rôti.
Donc couteau électrique.
Et c'est ça. Français, ça, non ?
Oui. C'est
Moulinex ? Non ?
Peut être, C'est vieux aussi.
Et ça,
c'est pour démonter les pneus.
Il me semble. Ouais, ouais.
Tu le veux
Sidney, non ? Bof.
Et une énorme cuillère.
Ouah avec l'hameçon
un sachet
avec quelque chose à l'intérieur.
Est ce que c'est juste
un prospectus ?
Qu'est ce qui nous a trouvé
encore une grille de barbecue ?
Ou j'ai l'impression.
Que rêver de. Mieux ?
Une toute petite grille de barbecue
parfait
qu'est ce qu'on a, une laisse ?
Un aimant.
Encore cette fois ci, un vrai aimant je crois
pas de pêche, mais.
On en a fait plein. C'est creux
Et le hors jeu.
Pour les autres ?
Ouais,
mais il est s'il a la forme creuse.
ah ben non
ainsi très légèrement, très léger.
Prêt Baptiste ?
rond ?
Wow ! Bof.
T'es jaloux !
Encore un bout de vélo, de vélo.
Et ça, c'était un collier de chien.
Ça, c'est parfait ça pour Sidney
Regarde tiens
Non elle elle a un collier des méthodes gun.
Un beau leurre de pêche, encore une voiture.
Ah ouais, c'est bien
Par contre.
C'est sympa, mais elle n'a plus de roues
Je te l'échange contre mon leurre de pêche
Une Ferrari je pense.
C'est
comme les voitures dans la carrière,
ils ont enlevé les roues.
Ouais, alors plus facile à remonter.
Tu as déjà remonté
une voiture entière ?
Bien sûr.
C'est ça ton titre de la vidéo ?
Ma première voiture entière.
Oh encore des morceaux de ton vélo.
Et pas que.
Ça. C'est pour les vélos.
Sinon.
Pour les distances.
Ouais, j'ai l'impression.
OK, un petit compteur et attend,
il y a encore un aimant.
Encore les aimants comme ça.
Ils sont plus costauds ceux-là ou le circulaire que j'avais ?
je ne sais pas de quel objet ils proviennent ceux-là mais...
On en a fait au moins cinq.
C'est bien.
Allez, le dernier lancé
en espérant avoir mieux
qu'un morceau de vélo
a encore ce truc blanc
c'était un manche à balai
peut être, qui se fait couper
en plein de bout.
Puis puis pas grand chose.
Voilà, cette vidéo touche à sa fin.
Là, je vais faire la dernière
remontée j'espère que ça vous a plu.
En tout cas, c'est un super pont
On espère y revenir
parce qu'il y avait plein de.
Choses, c'est certain.
Il reste plein de choses ici.
Allez, ce dernier lancé,
il est encore plein.
Mais oui, c'est rempli
rempli, rempli à chaque fois.
Après, il y a beaucoup de petites
ferrailles.
Pas très bon,
mais une fois qu'on a sorti
tout cette ferraille là,
ce n'est pas impossible.
Il y a des
choses intéressantes au fond.
On a fait la même déjà
sympa.
Voilà à la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle
vidéo de pêche à l'aimant